okay well we've reported a lot about
universities dealing with racial
tensions on campus Princeton is
recognizing diversity in a really unique
way that's where I went to school
Mario more an art fellow at the
university created large-scale portraits
of campus workers who are predominantly
people of color on the campus he said he
did it to honor the people who keep
campuses running and who also become
support systems for students away from
home howard's that finn is one of them
hey how you doing who's next
it's true
Sutphin has worked in the school dining
halls for 22 years but he's also a
staple at Princeton games where students
always flock to him that's what he told
us he says having his own portrait on
campus is an honor I love that that's
gonna be here after I retire because the
school has purchased it mm-hmm
what does that mean to you love that's
love of all the years I gave love I got
it back in net so as schools are trying
to deal with how to celebrate diversity
how to make all students feel included
Princeton is using art in this way
they've also commissioned portraits of
notable professors of color Toni
Morrison who was a professor who was a
professor there she has a new portrait
Danny Chen a federal judge who went to
Princeton and my friend Paul's father
Carl field who's a first
african-american administrator at the
school and Robert Rivers who's among the
first African American students to go to
the school they all have portraits it's
nice to see that I mean because when you
look at the history as you noted in your
piece last night in the evening news
there was a time where people of color
weren't even allowed to go to Princeton
so it just shows that evolution coming
full circle and that's important for
them to be seen on the walls
I love recognizing people who otherwise
might not might not be known yeah you
know around campus or something it's a
good story
you